joining us now Cowboys receiver Amari
Cooper and he is here today as part of
the Gatorade beat the heat program to
beat the heat program educates athletes
across all sports about the importance
of hydration during the hot summer
months and again it is Amari Cooper
Maury welcome to the program how are you
buddy
good good thanks for having me hey I'm
curious we're in that period now between
the offseason program and training camp
how long will Amari Cooper go without
catching a pass during the next five or
six weeks probably a couple hours while
I'm sleep much it I'm always trying to
catch passes I even have you know a
couple footballs in my house and I throw
them to myself
now do you okay do you have a jugs gun
that you use who are any other machinery
or or do you have somebody who steps in
and plays the role of dak Prescott what
do you do when when you're not able to
go work out with your teammates and you
have that itch to catch passes yeah so
when I'm not able to work out with my
teammates I'll just you know call up
somebody and I have a couple friends it
can sometimes it's even like high school
guys to throw me a couple balls when I
need it a lot of times quarterbacks and
receivers will get together during this
period from the offseason program to
start a training camp any plans for
cowboys players to get together and and
work on the offense and spend some time
together in advance of training camp
yeah we're gonna do that a couple weeks
before training camp well we have a trip
plant to San Diego to kind of hit
together and go over some of the
offensive plays and just you know run
routes and catch a couple passes just to
kind of get us ready for training camp
who picked San Diego deck did he explain
why I pick San Diego what was between
there and a couple different places but
those were the options that he laid
before us and we kind of collectively
picked that place I've gotten the
impression that dak is really
flourishing as a leader now I know
you've only been with him a limited
period of time but what growth what
changes have you seen from when you
arrived last October and
till now oh well as soon as I got here
he seemed to have that leadership bro
down pat was really doing a good job
with the guys just motivating us and
giving us those talks before the games
to get us going so by the time I got
here he already had it he already had it
down pat does it work when he gives you
those talk before the games because I
know with some quarterbacks guys it kind
of maybe to themselves roll their eyes
and maybe it doesn't work but but for
dak it seems like it's real diva does it
really speak to you when he tries to get
you guys fired up before the start of a
game yeah you can definitely feel it it
seems like it just comes natural to him
it seems like that that's who he is
that's the role that he was meant to
have with any team that he's on and so
it's not something that feels forced or
faked or anything like that it just it
just feels like that's what he's
supposed to do and and so yeah it's it's
very beneficial for us as he said that
that he wants everyone to go e2w has
that happened yet I asked that question
because I'm not sure everybody's
familiar with eating a W but I'm glad
that you you recognize that one tomorrow
you had a lot of w's at alabama and nick
saban one of the great coaches of all
time in any sport is there one thing
that stands out from your time with Nick
Saban that kind of still comes to mind
today a coaching point motivation
anything from Coach Saban oh yeah I mean
he's a great coach he's all about he's
all about winning and one of the things
that I learned from him from afar I
would say it's just what goes into
actually winning and being the best that
you can be he's a really diligent guy
really studious I mean he's the first
one in the facility and the last one to
leave I think the guy sleeps like two or
three hours and he really puts in the
work so that we can go out there and
actually be the winning football team
that we were
and not everybody's willing to put that
work in I get the impression that makes
it easier when it's time for Alabama
players and make the transition to the
NFL because you've already been
essentially working for an NFL coach in
an NFL style program where everybody is
all-in and everybody does put in the
effort and the time in the work yeah
it's a very easy transition
you know you might hear I've heard a lot
of guys say you know coming from Alabama
that the NFL the the regiment it's it's
kind of less than what we had to
experience at Alabama so definitely does
a great job in training us for the next
level Amar'e I think one of the hardest
things for anyone to do in the NFL is
change teams at the receiver position
during a season and make an impact
getting thrust into new offense how were
you able to come in and do so well you
know wow while the train is moving you
jumped onboard and and you had a strong
season to finish out the year with the
Cowboys how are you able to pull that
off yeah I mean I just put all my energy
and effort into actually coming in
learning the system and and playing well
and I just had a will and a want to come
out here and just prove myself and just
so a lot of my teammates and the coaches
and people that traded for me that I was
actually you know worth the trade and I
think that's how I did it you know and
nothing against the Raiders but I just
feel like sometimes guys need to change
a scenery and it can flip that switch
and it can make all the difference in
the world and I know from from afar
Chris Sims and I looking at your
situation last year it kind of looked
like it worked out perfectly that that
change of scenery was just what you
needed at the right time or are we right
when we when we come to that conclusion
yeah I mean you know whatever the
circumstance maybe is there are certain
reasons why you know one place might not
work for a guy and another place will
and I think the changes Henry was really
necessary I really honestly don't think
if I were you know stayed at the Raiders
last season that I would have been able
to flourish and you know reach some
heights that I was able to reach other
Cowboys so it was definitely necessary
what do you think was holding you back
in Oakland I don't know I don't I don't
know how to answer that question well I
mean and I know it was the first year
with a new coach new offense new
approach and sometimes the comfort level
is just not there did you just feel like
it wasn't a good fit for you yeah
definitely I don't think it was it was a
good fit for me I don't think I was
really able to showcase my skills there
for whatever reason extenuating
circumstances you I I'll call it cleanly
in circumstances but for whatever reason
I just wasn't able to kind of reach my
my Heights and I kind of knew that I
needed to be going in order to do some
of the things that I really wanted to do
as NFL player when did you first come to
that conclusion oh good question um
probably probably last year yeah early
on in the year I felt like there are
things that I wanted to do out there on
the field during the games certain plays
that I wanted to be called certain
routes that I wanted to run that just
want a part of the game plan I feel like
the Kaleo Mac trade also kind of sent a
message across the entire organization
that anything can happen anything will
happen and other guys may be traded did
you get the sense that that that kind of
sent shockwaves through the team that
any of us could be gone in any given
moment yeah of course
after the clio trade I mean it was like
here's a guy who's a very dominant
player in this league and he's proven
that one of the best players in the in
the entire league and you trade him away
so what makes anyone else feel like
they're safe and that they're not
tradable and that was kind of defense in
the locker room
did you ever ask to be traded I did not
no I didn't ask to be treated did they
ever tell you they weren't gonna trade
you
I know they never explicitly told me
that they weren't gonna train me in fact
they only had heard about rate rumors
like you know maybe two weeks before I
was actually traded so in that time span
of two weeks no they never came up to me
and said uh you wouldn't be traded not
me and specifically my a told my agent
that I'm re I mentioned earlier you're
here today on behalf of the Gatorade
beat the heat program tell us more about
it tell us where we can find out more
about Gatorades beat the heat yeah you
can find out more about it on the
Gatorade website but I'm just here to
help get re-educate athletes across all
sports about the importance about
hydration don't eat hot summer months
and to give them a few safety tips about
how to attack that well and we'll also
check out I think the YouTube channel
has more information there as well one
more before I let you go and I'm not
gonna ask you about your contract I'm
sure everybody wants to ask you about
your contract I know that's something
your agent handles on your behalf with
the Cowboys but how does Amari Cooper
keep from letting this unsettled
contract situation become a distraction
for what it is that you need to do well
I just approach the game how I've been
approaching it uh-huh you know I have a
set goal and what I want to accomplish
for the season I just want to be the
best player on every field that I step
on and I do the things necessary for me
to accomplish those goals as far as
putting in the necessary work to do to
actually do what I set out to do and I
don't even worry about the contract I
think that will take care of itself
I have some really good agents who have
been in this position a lot of times who
have gotten contracts for God's done and
that's the reason why I hire them to do
just that and so I don't worry about
that I just worry about playing football
because that's my job and performance
results in numbers and you had a
thousand yards last year between the
Raiders and the Cowboys I assume your
goal this year is at least a thousand
what's the next number one comma one
what are you shooting for yeah I put a
two in front of that
- wait a minute wait a minute you mean -
comma you talking about 2000 yards yeah
that's - go man that's a hell of a goal
hey Amar'e nobody's ever done that
before so that's one hell of a goal and
we wish you the best as you embark on
that and I hey listen I don't doubt
anybody's got big goals and I look
forward to seeing you embark on that one
and the Cowboys on their team goals and
good luck with everything
that you you've got going on
congratulations on all your success and
we look forward to talking to you down
the road and if you get 2,000 yards I'm
you divided well I probably probably
won't talk to us then request hunt up
out the door but hopefully we can get
you back on the show if you get 2000
yards you I'll promise you that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports